this universe is only one of an infinite
member worlds without end
some benevolent and life-giving others
filled with malice and hunger who are
you in this vast multiverse mr. strange
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
before spider-man far from home came out
everybody was really excited and really
freaking out about the fact that
Mysterio mentioned that he was from a
different universe and that a multiverse
existed this is obviously huge news as
it opens up the MCU to many different
possibilities many different stories and
many different characters and the
writers for spider-man 5 from home have
officially come out in an interview and
have talked about the multiverse and
spider-man 5 from home if you have not
seen spider-man far from home this is
your spoiler alert I will be talking
about some spoilers for spider-man far
from home in this video and quick
reminder if you'd like a chance to win
an Iron Man helmet a Captain America
shield and Infinity Gauntlet or another
Marvel Legends item be sure to subscribe
to my channel I'll be picking three
winners from my giveaway at four hundred
and fifty thousand subscribers so in
spider-man far from home as many people
guessed Mysterio was lying about being
from a different universe this was a
pretty big letdown to a lot of fans but
stick with me until the end of this
video and I'll explain how a multiverse
does in fact exist in the MCU and how it
has already been introduced but the
writers for spider-man fire from home
have recently come out and spoken about
why they had Mysterio mentioned the
multiverse why put the multiverse line
in there and why have Mysterio mentioned
the universes by name according to the
writers for spider-man far from home
Chris McKenna and Eric summers the
reason was to hide the fact that
Mysterio was not a hero they wanted to
hide the fact that he was a simple evil
illusionist who was seeking revenge on
Tony Stark writer Eric summer said
anytime we find ourselves with a twist
or surprise reveal of something like
this we want to do as much as we can to
protect it and distract from it ahead of
time
Chris McKenna then added what we kept
saying is that he had to feel like a
real character so we wanted to give him
a tragic backstory with all the details
of coming from
another world and make sure that the
elementals he's fighting felt like a
growing Avengers level threat we wanted
to make it as believable as possible so
essentially they mentioned the
multiverse and Spider Man far from home
to make a Mysterio really seem like a
good guy from another universe and to
make it seem like these elementals were
a huge threat and of course they did
this by Mysterio saying that the
elementals were responsible for
destroying his old universe and it
actually did a really good job there
were many fans out there that thought
Mysterio could actually be good since
he's from a different universe maybe
it's a different take on Mysterio but
ultimately it was the typical Mysterio a
trickster and an illusionist
however Mysterio lying about him being
from another universe does not mean that
the multiverse does not exist in fact it
has been mentioned before in fact there
was a really big deal made about the
multiverse and Doctor Strange and not
just in the movie but for some
promotions from Marvel for the movie as
well what if the fabric of reality was
but a single threat of something much
larger
universe was just one of many the
multiverse would time be the same there
would it flow as previous water in any
direction could travel between those
realities be possible what if you could
be in two places at once
physical self and one an astral
projection and another
what if all of this wasn't what if at
all and there are dangers yes but
wonders too and power so much power and
in the wrong hands anything good
but for now just one day so in Doctor
Strange is really where they introduced
the multiverse and mentioned it by name
now it's no coincidence that they
mentioned it in spider-man 5 from home
even though the multiverse was not used
in spider-man far from home I think it
is going to play a really big factor for
the upcoming future of the MCU
especially since we have a Doctor
Strange 2 movie coming up which will
probably explore the multiverse even
more so for all the fans that were
really bummed out that the multiverse
was not introduced in spider-man far
from home don't worry it was introduced
in Doctor Strange and will definitely be
a part of the MCU moving forward but let
me know your thoughts on what the writer
said about including the multiverse and
spider-man fire from home and let me
know what you think the future of the
multiverse holds for us in the MCU be
sure to comment down below and comment
with your favorite superhero or villain
like this video and subscribe to my
channel so you can enter my giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof